[Music]
here's your money briefing for Monday
June 26th I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
are you the office jerk you might think
of course not but what if your
co-workers disagree turns out they may
be reluctant to tell you how they really
feel Tessa West is a professor of
psychology at New York University she
and her colleagues conducted a study to
find out why people find it difficult to
give negative feedback and she joins me
now
so Tessa what kind of jerk-like behavior
are we talking about when most of us
hear the word jerk we think really
egregious stuff you know yelling at
someone insulting them taking away their
power in a meeting but I actually really
focus on the low-level types of drug
Behavior interruptions you know kind of
ignoring people writing a slightly rude
email or taking over a meeting the kinds
of things that we encounter in our
everyday work lives so why did you
decide to do the study I think it's
fascinating to look at how people avoid
feedback in uncomfortable situations as
a social psychologist that's really what
I focus on is how people avoid feeling
anxious and uncomfortable even if it
kind of hurts them in the end so one of
the studies we talk about in this piece
is really focusing on giving feedback to
someone who obviously needs it I mean
the context of losing a negotiation to
that person in all the ways that which
people will just avoid saying the thing
instead of just being straightforward
and honest in a way that's useful to the
person on the receiving end why do they
try to avoid giving feedback I think we
live in a culture where negative
feedback is just seen as really
inappropriate and probably more
importantly we don't learn how to do it
in a constructive way so we're very
afraid of it we're afraid it's going to
backfire that the person is going to do
things like engage in Reverse blame well
you know maybe if you had done this
better I wouldn't be in this situation
and I think that's typically how these
things play out and so instead of
learning the strategies to be better at
it we just avoid it completely so how
did you work this feedback issue into
the study that you and your colleagues
did so
study was we are interested in what
happens when you're in a situation where
clearly you need to give someone
constructive feedback this person has
just done a negotiation with you we've
come in as scientists and said hey this
person lost to you why don't you give
them some constructive feedback on what
they could do so kind of the ideal
situation where feedback makes sense
setting them up for success in that
situation telling them even ways in
which they could do this and most people
just stuck with the positives what was
fascinating though is at the same time
we measure their physiology so we could
see that their heart rate was kind of
going through the roof that they're very
stressed out while delivering this
positive feedback so we call this the
brittle Smiles effect smiling nodding
your head telling them you did great all
the while you look like you're you know
on the treadmill at the same time
because you're avoiding the negative
stuff oh so grinning right through your
teeth that's right so when the exercise
was over how did the people respond to
this newfound ability to give feedback
you know people can really lean into it
if you give them very specific
instructions and what's great about it
is people feel much more confident if
you tell them to avoid saying negative
stuff completely focus on the behavior
someone's doing make them small and bite
size and immediate and really avoid
making attributions for people's
behavior completely don't use the word
jerk don't say mean or don't say you
intended to do this that and the other
if you stick to the small stuff to the
behaviors that people are doing then
they feel suddenly much more confident
in being able to deliver that kind of
feedback so that's usually how we train
people on kind of how to get around this
very sticky social situation all right
so back to the office environment what's
the best way to approach someone who
might need to be told to you know tone
it down the best thing to do is to
approach them and ask them if you can
talk about the event that led you to
feel like they were a jerk you know
maybe in a meeting they cut you off 15
times it interrupted you or maybe your
boss micromanage you and oversaw your
work a little too much instead of going
to them and telling them how you feel go
to them and say can we talk about that
event I feel like maybe we're not on the
same page regarding some of those
behaviors and then at the end of the
conversation you know where you deliver
information or you ask them about how
did they feel about this Behavior here's
what I thought that meant ask for
feedback yourself as soon as it feels
reciprocal as soon as the person you're
giving feedback to feels like they can
also give some feedback to you they feel
much better about it they're less likely
to feel attacked they're much less
defensive about the feedback experience
some people might be sort of laughing
about this about the scenario of someone
acting like a jerk but there can be some
very real ramifications here this can
affect people's careers it can affect
their earnings absolutely and I think
most of us when we encounter jerks it's
death by a thousand paper cuts
eventually we disengage from the
workplace you know we have revolving
doors of talent so people and management
really need to care about kind of seeing
these things when they're first starting
detecting them early so that they don't
get out of hand and they absolutely add
up over time and I think the
accumulation of the stress in your body
as well is also something we shouldn't
underestimate as someone who studies
stress for a living I know that when
you're experiencing these chronic
stressors from jerks eventually you're
going to see consequences like poor
sleep poor eating and you know even
heart disease and cardiovascular issues
things like that so let's say somebody
has figured out that indeed they are the
office jerk or maybe an Office Jerk how
can they use the right kind of feedback
to help them Rectify their ways if you
think you're a jerk first off you're in
good company most of us have the
potential to be an Office Jerk what you
want to do is actually sidestep the kind
of jerk questions completely ask about
your specific behaviors if the person
who you're worried you're a jerk to is
someone who's underneath you in some
capacity you hold power over them don't
even ask about your behaviors ask about
what an ideal Behavior would look like
for that person so you're really getting
around kind of jerk language jerk
accusations and say you know what would
the ideal amount of time to turn around
this document be or do you want me to
call on you or do you feel comfortable
speaking up sometimes you can detect
that you're a jerk by just looking at
the discrepancy between what you're
doing and what the people around you say
they would love to see in a person in
your position so I'm a big fan of kind
of the more indirect path of detecting
that you're the actual jerk at work so
you had very specific takeaways that you
wanted to come from this study what I do
is learn where the Achilles heel is in
people's ability to give feedback and
so there's kind of both this combination
of if you don't ask the right way no one
will tell you that you're a jerk and if
you deliver it poorly people are going
to get extremely defensive and so just
very kind of specific behavior-based
immediate types of feedback are the best
I don't like feedback that happens once
a quarter or once a month because it
feels too big and scary I like the kind
of more organic natural bite-sized
pieces of feedback and I think what I
learned from the study is when you
formalize feedback people get really
uncomfortable even if it's to say this
is a 15-minute feedback conversation
that's sufficient enough to disrupt the
whole process it's better if you just
kind of do it when you're walking down
the hall and it feels more natural it
feels less kind of structured that's New
York University psychology Professor
Tessa West and that's your money
briefing I'm J.R Whalen for the Wall
Street Journal
[Music]
foreign